9-1-1 police power Medical
hi I'm calling because nobody got
stabbed here at the Craig Ranch which
side of the park
tell me exactly what happened
uh my brother has been stabbed and his
guts are out so we need the medical
group now at Craig
9-1-1 calls following that stabbing at
Craig Ranch skate park three men were
injured in broad daylight good afternoon
thank you for joining us here at four
I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Christian
casares it's been a week since the
stabbing and now North Las Vegas Police
have released those 911 calls to eight
news now due to that incident police say
they are going to increase security and
Patrol in that area Madison Kimbrough
joins us live from the skate park near
Craig and Revere with those plans
Madison
now the stabbing victims between the
ages of 18 and 40 took place here last
Saturday afternoon and as you can see
it's very busy as of now 8 news now has
obtained multiple 911 calls like you
just heard following the incident take a
listen
911 police fire or medical
Craigslist
did you say stabbed yeah what part of
the what part of the park are you in
that was one of the three victims
staffed in the incident at the Craig
Ranch skate park North Las Vegas Police
releasing calls for help from the
injured that victim's brother also
calling in describing the person who
committed the crime I know he was uh he
was aging tan he had some type of long
stay here he was wearing 10 intensity I
don't know what else he's going through
but after that he ran according to North
Las Vegas Police a fight occurred
between two groups and during the fight
an unknown individuals stabbed the three
men that person has yet to be found
Wesley Jordan a skater who was there
last Saturday believes a juvenile is the
one who stabbed the three adults in
self-defense it was two kids fighting
the adult came the adult lost the fight
caught his friends then they ended up
getting hurt because they wanted to mess
with the kid pretty much the kid was
defending himself because you know a
couple of adults was just trying to pick
on him and due to this incident police
increasing their presence at the park
Wesley's father George she has been
coming to the skate park for years says
more patrols are desperately needed you
asked me
that is security at this park in this
area for these kids will be the best
thing in the world because this is where
our kids be North Las Vegas Police
confirm this is not a random act of
violence
while North Las Vegas Police didn't
confirm a specific date and time that
Patrol would increase they did confirm
with us that more Personnel would be on
property including event spaces as well
reporting live from Craig Ranch here in
North Las Vegas Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now